this is the fishing gentlemen it's a
member of the same family as civics the
Viper adiy but this creature is found
itself in a pretty unique day-to-day
survival situation imagine an animal
that depends on capturing fish in order
to feed itself but doesn't really enjoy
getting wet
the fishing Genet has figured out some
ingenious fishing strategies first it
taps its paw in the water this is called
Dappy then it sticks its whiskers in the
water to feel for vibrations by curious
or frightened fish if it doesn't get
good vibes it moves on and stays dry
more dapping more searching still dry
but interested
now the head goes in plus see something
the fishing Genet is zeroing in on a
meal using a combination of whisker
radar instinct experience and eyesight
got it and the fishing Genet avoided
taking the full-body plunge good work